応報人間関係めんどくさすぎてや味噌
わかりは一人って
楽だもんこんにちははじめそうですはいっていうわけでついに5月が終わり
6月になってしまいましたそれで質問コーナーもう少し待ってくださいって言うな人
ちょっとあの子の人間関係っていう話に付いた今
教師と皆さんにいじめについてお話ししようと思いますで皆さんいじめに遭った人って
ドレイクが言います方やいじめってやばくね普通に萎えるんだけど
自分と人結構いると思うスレかなんかねもういじめてどこでもあるんで
白なに地面になってたりいじめて思ってないのにいじめして言ったり知ってたみたいな
パターンがあったりするんでしょと一概にうまく言えないんですけどスト今日はその
いじめについてちょっと僕の実体験を踏まえて話してみようと思いますあの少なくとも
僕はですね
人生で過去
2階はあ
いじめにあっておりますだいぶ前の話なんですけどねまぁなんか人間関係っていう点で
はか何も聞く中に入ったようなもんなんでまた目世の中には僕以上に酷い思いをしてる
人がたくさんいると思うので人間関係とかでね僕の音をだしたらなんですけどもう
ちょっと六が過去にあったことをつの皆さんに
かんたんに
できるだけコミカルにお話ししようと思いますかもう一杯所に僕いじめに遭ったのは5
歳の時だった固まってちょっと聞いてみ俺で母ちゃんが覚えてるんだよね俺がイジメに
あったのは確か
[音楽]
は僕の休憩が正しければ確か初めていじめにあったのが5歳の時ですね僕実は
こうみえてる
習い事で空手を習っていたんですたっ小さい時のものを覚えがめちゃくちゃいいね
なんか習い事させようということで最初からてをやらせてもらいました
もうねいざましく強くな買おうかなって思って空手を始めたんですけどそれが5歳の
ときで初日にその体験会みたいな形でこれから始めるんでちょっと1回ミンティ皆さん
みたいな感じで空手の道場に行っていろんな人達
と混じってこうやってってこうやってたわけですよ風を切るレベルでネットでかなてよ
母
やってたんですけども初めてで緊張しててもう他の人も知らない人だらけだったんです
けど僕のイメージだと
やっぱすごい怖い人が多かったなって思います何か喧嘩強そうだみたいな人が多くて
実際は分かんないですけど当時の僕のイメージはそんな感じでした村日の彼方の
レッスンが終わって終わりです片付けしましょうって言ってなんか想像したりいろいろ
想像してたんですけど僕初めてでこうなんか用具室からそう住宅置くところに最後まで
残ってねこの
減って片付け機種なんですけど肩掛けしている時に半ば記憶が正しければもうずっ歳と
かかな
小学生の中壊さなお人チャレ僕が中に入れるにヨーグルトの鍵を
かけてきてマジで結構長い時間でれなかったんですよ
助けて言っても全然聞いてくれないしもうなんかせないとだけだしても助けを求められ
ようがない
んですよ母ちゃんの向かう来てたのかセラないんですけど1だり初見でね一発目的な虹
見られてっていうのがあってもう帰ってカートに片手にいじめられたと言ってその日で
空手を止めました僕のかて人生終了ですありがとうございました
っていうのがまず一発目だったかなあで5歳だったからほぼ記憶にないんですけどね
めちゃくちゃ怖かった記憶があります助けを本
ようにも誰もいないからね初めてのは時計のがまず向かせ日光ありましたので
で次がなんですけどへと宮阪の方で小学6年生の時でございます僕もだんだん成長して
きて結構船長が高くなったんですよ学年でトップ通過トップ3くらい身長が高くなって
て
であの場所を学校から超獣あるんですよねカースト制度というか
組分やるぞ
ね一番ほど人気の男子女子グループみたい1軍の一番その中目立ってる男子のグループ
の中の下っ端にずっといたんです小学校の頃からなんかそんな超やんちゃでもなかった
んでなんかそれぞれにとりあえずついてたみたいな感じだったんですけどまぁなんか
うちの小学校ですね僕が小学6年生の時に何かプールを新しく作ろうという
とで新しいにプールを作ったんですめちゃくちゃ綺麗ですね新しいプロ作って取れの中
オープニングセレモニーみたいななんか開会式っていうわけじゃないんですけど何か
新しいプレーができたので皆で祝いましょうみたいな式がなんか意味不明なのがあって
それになぜか僕が選ばれて開会のことばを
な
なんだよに合わせたんですだけじゃねーかそのプールが出来ましたこれから大切に使い
ますみたいな台詞を何故か俺がゆうことになってそういうのって断れないタイプだった
んだよ
はいわかりましたつって受けたんですけどその頃から1軍の中のなんか空気をちょっと
香りだしてきててなんかそれが原因か分からなかったんですけどすっげえさ
得られるようになってきてもうやばいですよもうなんかヤバいなんて例えれないけど
もうなんか今までの全然対応が違うってか俺が使ったら見なかった
いいとかいくみたいな俺が北高いくみたいなキモいとかバカとか言われるタイプの泉
じゃなくてもう本当にただ避けられるというか
シャットアウトされて一切関係を断たれるみたいな状態が続いてと a が何柱か続い
てそのままもうプールの開会式になってしまいました体と代表
枝くん
僕の本名ですよ生徒代表枝くん近いのことは未来なのをお願いしますのでな感じで
あまり覚えて心がもうズタボロだったんですけど覚えて挨拶を言ったわけですよフル
みんなが大事に使います
お話
感じでいい終わった時に本来だったらと拍手が起きるはずだったんですけど
生徒の方を見るともうシーンインってなってたなーっていう記憶が正しければそうだっ
た気がしますはい
音声気づかなかったのかな今のは思うんですけどなんかもうこの時からこう時だったら
もうなんかで親に言えなくて恥ずかしくて
目覚められているつったらなんかすごいで舐められそうだったんで
風が好きで親にも言えなかったんですよまもう堪えたまましばらく過ごしなんですけど
まぁ唯一の救いだったことがこのいじめ機関が結構短くてよもう2週間くらいしたら
結構普通に何か戻ってきちゃったりして
なら素早くだったらみんな普通に仲良くなってくれたんですけどなんでだろうなぁ
もう本当にただただ一人で寂しくしてた気がしますね
そうですよねでは良い奴らだったんだと友達が小学校の時なんでたぶんみんなで止め
ようって言ったのかわかんないんですけど本当にぽっちゃりしばらくになんでかそれを
見てタブや美容って誰か言ってくれたんだかもしれないしなんか必然的に自然に戻っ
たらもしれないんですわからないんですけど僕は過去そういう
に1回いじめを受けてきておりました実は結果からでもやっ
ました
分からない人が恋の経験したんでジューク高校はネネが割と誰かとつるむのあんまり
避けるようにしてましたね部活ぐらいから特定の友達でこうガットがを使っちゃうと
そこからハブられた時も動作もなくなっちゃうんで部活のやったらどんな顔だったん
ですけど
中学か高校はなんかこうすげー中いうグループみたいなのは作らず比較的
一人が二人で行動捨てた気がしますね
闇ですね俺6月ませんそれ何言ってねーなんか人間関係ってはと聞いてああそういうの
があったなーって思ってちょっと話してみました泉で困ってる人すごい多いと思うん
ですけど
ないじめはもう絶対おきます
何が何でもどんな良い奴だろうといじめを置きますねみんな違う人間ですも2分で
みんなに同じ人間同じ性格同じ
なんか容姿とかだったら絶対いじめを受けないと思うんですよみんなも同じだけどそれ
はもうありえなくていろんな性格の人いろんな顔の人いろんな容姿の人いろんな人が
いるからそれ
でこうなんか誰かがを取ったり誰か脅し見やすかったりする状況ができちゃうね自分が
起きちゃっても1名が受けるの商談ないといじめゼロは無理
かつですね何ず論ブリーズで100%いじめてるっていう人が近くもて辞めていくしか
ないと僕は思ってますちょっといじめしてるなって子かかるあなたもうちょっと昔の力
制御で申し訳ないんですけど僕はすごい嫌な思いをしたんで自分で地味たいと思って
いる人はもうやめてあげてほしいなって思います
止めなば寂しくなってきちゃった自分の話知ると寂しくなってきちゃった山路ね親にも
言えないですからね恥ずかしくていじめられているのでいじめられている人いたらもう
なんか
タッチ向かうのも辛いしいじめられてる人が辞めてくれる保証もないんでホントにもう
ねどうぞもなく苦しいんだったら僕は正直に向けてもいいと思います
僕はから体のどうぞの時秒で逃げたんだよ逃げるか水
っていう感じですねちょっと人間関係って言うことは聞くとそういうのを思い出し
ちゃったんでちょっと話してみましたみなさまいじめられた経験ありますか
いやー結構つらいですよねべ組根占ないようにキョッキョッじゃあ
[音楽]